on est à la bergerie nationale de
rambouillet c'est d'ici que sera lancé
le paris brest paris la célèbre
randonnée de cyclotourisme pour la
deuxième édition consécutive ce sera le
20 août 2023 un retour donc dans le rang
bolide a expliqué par madame le maire de
rambouillet véronique matillon la façon
dont les routes sont tranquilles dans
notre région la possibilité aussi de
faire un départ sur un lieu qui peut
réunir
autant de personnes parce que c'était
plus de 6000 participants la fois
précédente ce seront huit mille
personnes qui seront au départ la fois
prochaine donc il fallait avoir un lieu
qui soit suffisamment grand pour
accueillir tout ce monde là en quelques
chiffres celui qu'on surnomme le pbp ses
90 heures maximum pour parcourir 1200 km
connu depuis 1891 comme une course c'est
devenu ensuite une randonnée un défi
personnel depuis que l'audax club
l'organisent soit en 1931 ce n'est pas
une course c'est soi-même sa passion
c'est se dépasser et rêvait aussi de
l'avoir fait et comme cela seul le
chronomètre personnel compte mais n'y a
pas de classement environ 400 bénévoles
et 6000 randonneurs participent à
l'événement après être allé jusqu'en
bretagne sur des véhicules en tout genre
ils reviendront à rambouillet pour
terminer la boucle entre deux et quatre
jours plus tard